jamie lynn spears starred in zoe 101 and
now
jamie lynn is turning back the clock
rachel smith has that story from
nashville
hey rach hey there kev jamie lynn
recreated the famous zoe 101 theme song
and we got an exclusive sneak peek at
the video
are you ready
[Music]
what's up guys it's chantal jeffrey and
i'm daniel spears and we have a treat
for you
yes we are on the set of follow me music
video
the zoe theme song was um something that
me and my sister actually was a part of
creating and um you know it's like 12.
it's nervous to go in the studio so of
course your big sister get in here and
do it you'll cheer me on and so she was
a big part of that song
in the original version
in the new follow me music video out
tomorrow internet stars jojo siwa and
dixie dimelio star alongside the zoe 101
cast and jamie lynn's 12 year old
daughter
daddy's in the video and it was the best
day of her life she's basically best
friend of all the major influencers now
does your sister make a surprise
appearance
no she doesn't she was busy having a
nice little vacation
maddie's a big enough star there wasn't
a lot of room to you know have anyone
else
i know you see me standing here now that
the videos happen
is a reboot gonna happen jamie lynn not
only was the chemistry still there but
we saw what the world would look like
with today's world and the original zoe
world meshed together
so i think that all this did was push it
to happen sooner
i have ideas so exciting
jamie lynn says conversations are
underway about what the reboot will look
like
but the pandemic is definitely making it
tougher cave